we don't have to get ready because we
stay ready
when i say deep you say condition
[Applause]
may the purge be with you
[Applause]
amen
now for 364
days
we have suffered with half used hair
products that have gathered dust sitting
around in our beauty cabinets taunting
us
you won't use me
i won't work
i'm gonna make you look worse than when
you came
no more ladies no more moisturizers
serums and gels reminding us of a bygone
era of bad hair experiments
and if you hold on sis
scoot those in there for you i want you
to drop them out
there you go
ladies we trained for this
today we fight
[Applause]
[Applause]
i need you to secure your laces and your
lace fronts cause it's time to vlog and
weave
[Applause]
this is not a test this is your
emergency broadcast system signaling the
annual product purge commencing of the
siren any and all hair products
purchased in a previous calendar year
that did not bring about the desired
results can be returned for the next 12
minutes no receipts no restrictions may
not be with you
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey
i'm a donor
[Applause]
empty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right well
you still seeing that dude you met at
the kishi gold concert no girl we had
less chemistry than a college athlete's
transcripts i'd let him go oh
single file ladies we go through this
every single year i want this line
tattered and baby here on braids thank
you i think you'd be used to it by now
well what's your attitude who are you
texting is she you taking selfies oh my
god you got chips in your mouth i mean
at least show them a little titty then
if you don't do it you know you're right
about that i didn't even think about
this okay
your man can wait
it seems like we're all a little thirsty
here very very much clearly clearly you
want me to turn this around is that what
yes the product is almost over
yes
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
this time that is next month's mortgage
payment you know it's too bad bella
couldn't be here to see this i'm pretty
sure she died ooh tomorrow's wash day i
think i'm gonna try patterns intensive
conditioner oh i was looking at that
come on
[Music]
you